golden seas are vital to your progress
in elden ring as these are what will
allow you to upgrade the number of uses
you get out of your flasks of tears
while you'll find most of them for
exploring some are also tied to quest
lines and bosses in fact i'm still
working my way through to find all of
them i'm also not going to get into
endgame territory as i don't want to
spoil that but i wanted to put together
a guide for all of you on every golden
sea we've found so far so if you're
struggling or you have a nagging
suspicion you missed one of these you
can go find it these will be in
chronological order by area and you'll
find quick links in the description so
you can quickly skip ahead and hopefully
avoid spoilers for yourself i'm also
going to avoid the ultra late game area
for now as i don't want to spoil that
you can find your first golden seed
right at the start of the game just
choose it as your starting gift which is
my personal recommendation for the most
useful one and you're good to go
the second golden seed is actually right
at the start of the game in the french
folk heroes grave located in the
stranded graveyard before you even step
foot in limb grave to access it you'll
need two stone sword keys from here
you'll have to traverse through the
dungeon and to the boss who is
definitely not for low-level characters
the ulcerated tree spirit
defeat the ulcerated tree spirit and
you'll be rewarded with a couple goodies
including a golden seed
you can find your third golden seed in
limgrave from the gate front shrine of
grace near the gatefront runes head west
and then north through the gate and up
towards stormhill shack you'll find the
golden seat on the way here
just south of limgrave is the weeping
peninsula from the castlemore and
rampart shrine of grace head south
towards castle mourn and you'll find a
golden seat on a cliffside along the way
next up we're going to head to mistwood
located east of limgrave from the fort
height west shrine of grace head toward
the castle defeat the enemies and you'll
find your golden seat directly in front
of fort height
[Music]
within the legacy dungeon of stormville
castle you'll be able to find a golden
sea near the godric boss fight this
golden seat is located on the path in
between the left side chamber and
secluded cell and just past where you'll
find the philly lou
our next golden seed actually comes from
a quest line along the way to stormville
castle you'll find an npc roderica
located in stormhill shack there are
actually two different ways to get this
golden seed if you don't follow her
questline and complete her quest she'll
disappear from the storm hill shack
after you defeat godric and you can find
the golden seed in place of where she
was
however if you want to follow her
questline within stormville castle
you'll find a grafted scion you can
choose to fight in a side chamber near
the grafted scion is a pile of corpses
and on them the chrysolids memento make
sure to give her this memento before
beating godric if you do this you'll
find rodericka at the round table hold
where shall thank you and gift you with
the golden seed
now let's head into leone of the lakes
once you reach the academy gay town near
rhea lucaria you are very close to one
you'll find your next golden seed west
and slightly north of the academy
gatetown shrine of grace and right in
between that and the south rhea lucaria
shrine of grace
on the eastern side of lyonia you'll
find bellum church near the ground left
of dectus head down from bellum church
into waterfield tunnel and you'll find
the ravine veiled village as well as
golden seed right in front of the
village
carry a manor is pretty badass thanks to
the crazy hand monsters that frequent
the locale
not only that but you'll be able to find
a golden seed here after traversing
through the manor you'll eventually
reach the manor upper level shrine of
grace from here just go outside look
towards the cliff and you can't miss it
academy of rail lucaria is leonia's
major legacy dungeon and just like
stormville castle it also contains a
golden seed within once you reach the
debate parlor shrine of grace head into
the courtyard outside defeat or pass the
abductor version and head to the left
you'll find your golden seed here
as a pause i'm about to get into spoiler
territory so i want to warn people
before moving forwards
okay break's over let's go within miss
wood you'll find an elevator that will
take you down to the absolutely stunning
sierra for a river within for river from
the worshippers woods shrine of grace
head north and when you get the chance
west towards the giant structure and
waterfall you'll find a golden seed here
once you reach celia town of sorcerer
and caled travel up the main stairs on
the eastern side of the city and you'll
find the golden seat at the top
head south from the southern aeonia
swamp bank and travel along the trail
towards red main castle you'll find this
golden seed on the trail along the way
after defeating star scourge radon
you'll be able to access the war dead
catacombs defeat the boss of the dungeon
the putrid tree spirit and one of his
drops will be a golden seed
next up we head to the alice plateau if
you head up through the ravine valve
village you'll first pass through the
abandoned coffin shrine of grace and
then the urgery gazing hill shrine of
grace right in front of this is the
golden seed
along the main road just past the ground
lifted dectus you'll find the atlas
highway junction shrine of grace just
north of this along the trail is a
golden seed
at the north side of the atlas plateau
is the windmill village from his trine
of grace head south towards the minor
archery along the way you'll find a
golden seed
this one is a nice twofer from the atlas
plateau if you head into lindell the
royal capital from the south side
through the main path you'll find the
outer wall phantom tree shrine of grace
directly in front of it is not one but
two golden seeds
nice
within landel the royal capital legacy
dungeon in a broken down courtyard on
the north side you'll find a tree spirit
mini boss fight go ahead and fight it as
your reward for defeating this tree
spirit is none other than a golden seed
just past the west capital rampart head
forward outside towards the giant tree
branch fight the gargoyle and there is
your prize at the phantom tree
at mount gelmir from seath water river
head north through the passage towards
seath water terminus you'll find the
golden seat on the way there just a
little past the seath water shrine of
grace
past the 9th mount gelmer campsite after
the full-grown falling star beast boss
fight and on the way down towards
volcano manor and the road of iniquity
shrine of grace you'll find your golden
seed here
in landel if you head east from the east
capital ramparts you can find the
forbidden lands from the forbidden land
side of grace on the way to the grand
lifter world you'll find a 25th golden
seed
and that's all we have for you so far as
i said earlier i don't want to spoil
anything beyond this and i'm sure that
there are plenty of seas i haven't found
yet so get hunting and if you guys enjoy
this we'll have a full updated guide for
you on every seat location as well as a
sacred tier guide coming soon make sure
to stick to game spot for all things
elton ring